Then
[Music] I have no choice but to
fight and find a way out.I've
become the face of a warrior.Above all,
this man who destroyed the detective agency can
fight with his legs in a place where he can't be forgiven.But I'm
surprised he got cut.My
supernatural ability is that of a kid.  You've heard about
it. Another divine ability.
Compared to the difficulties mentioned in my autobiography, it's not
that bad of an injury.
[Music] The
tiger's ability to regenerate is amazing. That's why even if you
cut off its head, it will grow back.  Are they coming?
[Music] I'm
not scared.
Loneliness was the norm.
But now I'm so scared of loneliness. I
thought the detective employees were scattered due to the natural lake incident and I was left alone.
[Music]
Kyoka-chan was there in my place.
Even with Franchette's help, I'm really alone right now. I want anyone to
fight alongside me.
[Applause] It's
so noisy on the other side.
[Music]
Did the prophecy that was supposed to be a battle come true?
[Applause]